[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
premier set 8 sport de la saison sur tb
78 c'est parti à pour le sommaire
football on jouait ce week-end le second
tour de la coupe de france coignard n'a
pas réussi l'exploit face à viry
châtillon les yvelinois qui évolue en d2
de district ont perdu 9 à 0 face aux
pensionnaires de ra un coup de
projecteur dans ce magazine roller
thomas des ricains sportif originaire de
monti le bretonneux a réussi l'exploit
de traverser la france du nord au sud en
roller avec sa petite amie
nous l'avons rencontrée interview à
suivre découverte aujourd'hui tv 78 vous
propose de découvrir le padel un sport
créée en 1969 au mexique est pratiqué
aujourd'hui par des centaines d'yveline
oit reportage dans cette émission
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par de la coupe de
france de football coignières qui évolue
en d2 de district recevez à
viry-châtillon pensionnaire de
régionales une malgré une belle
opposition en première période les
yvelinois au crack quiches et quitte
déjà la compétition le résumé du match
des images d'astrid bergère à montage de
jus la grande ville une journée
historique pour coignières ce dimanche
13 septembre le club local qui évolue en
d2 de district recevait viry-châtillon
pensionnaire de r1 au deuxième tour de
la coupe de france
une première pour la structure les
quatre divisions d'écart se font
ressentir rapidement les essonniens
marque à trois reprises le score à la
pause 3-0 première mi temps on a réussi
à peu près à tenir et on était mené au
score à 3-0 à la mi-temps sur trois
coups de pied arrêtés les buts qu'on y
ont été marqués c'était donc sur des
coups de pied arrêtés pas sur du jeu en
deuxième période les joueurs de coignard
n'y arrive plus physiquement les locaux
se font surprendre à six reprises ont
plusieurs buts en fin de match
il sort de cette coupe de france sur le
score de 9 à 0 on aurait préféré gagner
évidemment
la réalité c'est qu'on a eu à faire à
une équipe qui était beaucoup plus
costaud que nous aujourd'hui et qui a
gagné de manière logique en tant que
supporters et ben oui c'est un peu déçu
évidemment j'aurais aimé qu'ils gagnent
je parlais de hold up tout à l'heure il
y avait peut-être un hold up possible
mais bon lot
voilà on a bien compris que c'était un
peu à sens unique quand même voilà mai
mais bon ils ont fait bonne figure quand
même ils sont pas découragés il ya eu un
bon esprit dirait sur le match et ça
c'est important coignières devoir se
remobiliser rapidement le club jouera
son premier match de championnat le
dimanche 27 septembre sur le terrain de
l'équipe de d'aubergenville on regarde
maintenant les principaux résultats de
cette coupe de france de football massy
club de r3 s'est imposé 3 1 face à
maurepas voisin s'est fait éliminer aux
tirs au but face à tremplin à domicile
le petit poucet du département st-arnaud
a réussi l'exploit d'éliminer une d4 en
s'imposant assez facilement 5 à 0
c'est terminé pour maisons laffitte qui
n'a pas réalisé l'exploit face à
saint-ouen l'aumône
enfin le chesnay perd contre grigny 2 à
1 le prochain tour de la coupe de france
est programmé le 20 septembre prochain
on continue à parler football dans cette
émission eux étaient est également
engagé en coupe de france et ils ont
gagné 5 à 0 contre l'as cheminots de
l'ouest pour nous parler de cette
rencontre et du club de trappes le west
rappent le nous sommes avec le capitaine
mas il ait mordent alors un bon jour
alors ce cette coupe de france avant de
revenir sur le championnat a parlé cette
coupe de france déjà 5 à 0 1 pour vous
pour votre équipe
exactement dont 5 à 0 certes c'était un
adversaire qui était inférieure à nos
niveaux hiérarchiques
mais qui nous a proposé du répondant
après on a fait les efforts c'est
vraiment la coupe de france herman
quelque chose dont le coach tient
vraiment à coeur de faire un bon
parcours en coupe de france
le président le coach les joueurs
également entre nous donc voilà on
compte vraiment être très sérieux cette
année sur sur la coupe de france alors
vous avez pu voir les autres résultats
des clubs heavy noirci un petit
commentaire une réaction c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu certaines défaites qui était
parfois un peu lourde après bon c'est la
coupe de france à paris v des groupes
ont forcément parfois taper des plus
petites équipes
l'averse peut également arriver on a nos
voisins ne mord pas qu'ils ont qui ont
perdu contre m'asseoir trois bons on les
avait affronté en amical on leur
souhaite beaucoup de bonnes choses pour
leur championnat nous on va continuer
notre route en coupe de france en
espérent représenter du mieux qu'on peut
le 118 justement l'objectif en coupe de
france pour pour trappe
pas franchement faire une très belle
épopée une finale pourquoi pas on avait
certains que ma dernière 2-2 régionales
allez aller titiller le psg donc bon on
se pose pas de limites mais prenons les
choses étape par étape
on essaie moi c'est de faire une belle
épopée gagner les matches les uns après
les autres et ça commencera à dire la
semaine prochaine pour le prochain tour
alors on va revenir sur sur le
championnat vous avez très bien commencé
avec une victoire 3 2 sur votre terrain
contre contre suresnes victoire 3-2
c'était vraiment le score est un idéal
pour lancer cette saison le score idéal
je sais pas on préfère toujours ne pas
encaisser de but et gagner de manière un
peu plus un peu plus facile entre
guillemets après l'objectif c'était
vraiment les trois points on est à
domicile contre une belle équipe de
coignières serre qui était promue donc
voilà je pense qu'on a fait le travail
il ya eu certes un fait de match qui
pouvait être assez assez difficile
contre nous on a concédé notamment des
penaltys à la part ça le travail a été
fait on a pris les trois points c'est
dans la continuité de ce qu'on a fait
depuis le début de saison donc on est
plutôt satisfait du résultat
c'était une surprise ou pas de commencer
avec un festival offensif trois buts dès
la première rencontre
une surprise non parce qu'on a on a
voilà on a des joueurs de qualité au
niveau offensif on a travaillé beaucoup
de choses avec le coach pendant là
pendant la pré-saison
donc voilà commencer par une victoire
chez nous contre un promu c'était
clairement l'objectif on avait en tête
ce sera très souvent l'objectif
lorsqu'on joue à domicile voilà on a des
joueurs de qualité devant donc ça ça a
porté ses fruits on est on est très
content
la préparation justement est-ce qu'un
n'a pas été perturbé par le comique 19
très légèrement dessous voilà on avait
certaines certains gestes barrière à
mettre en place des bouteilles d'eau
individuels parfois des vestiaires qui
était dans les tribunes lorsqu on
accueillait ou qu'on est accueilli par
des parts des équipes après à part ça ça
va pas gêner puisque ça voilà on a
travaillé sérieusement et en faisant
attention notamment aux gestes barrières
mais le staff était est assez rigoureux
là dessus donc à nous en tant que
joueurs on s'est vraiment concentré sur
la préparation et ça c'est ça s'est très
bien passé il ya eu également un mercato
à l'intersaison est ce que l'équipe est
plus forte que l'année dernière selon
l'ong on essaie de se renforcer de la
meilleure des façons
on a gardé on a gardé beaucoup de forces
vives de l'année dernière de l'année
passée
également donc on a vraiment une
ossature assez solide qui qui a connu
notamment la montée en r3 ça a été
renforcée à la fois par l'externe par
certains joueurs de grande qualité est
également en interne par des jeunes qui
sont venus renforcer l'effectif donc on
a on a trouvé un équilibre plutôt
intéressant bon après c'est à nous de
mettre de mettre en place les choses sur
le terrain pour pour que ça porte ses
fruits
donc c'est plutôt intéressant pour
l'heure est ce que des jeunes du club
vont intégrer l'équipe première
peut-être cette saison vont intégrer ont
déjà intégré qui ont déjà un est déjà
intégrée même de manière orale en étant
parfois titulaire en début de match et c
voilà c'est ont il nous apporte beaucoup
de fraîcheur beaucoup d'insouciance
c'est vraiment des bonnes choses pour
nous et voilà on a une philosophie qui
voit là on regarde pas forcément là je
l'âge des joueurs si un joueur est prêt
à débuter il débutera et pour nous c'est
que du bonus là les années précédentes
la philosophie trappe au niveau du jeu
c'était l'aspect défensif il fallait
bien défendre avant de savoir attaquer
est ce que cette année la philosophie
sera là même où vous voulez peut-être
plus garder le ballon
alors c'est vrai qu'on a eu une
évolution de la philosophie dans la
volonté du coach pour cette année donc
on garde une gare nos forces et on garde
une ossature défensive solide mais on va
vraiment cherché à avoir la possession
du ballon avoir un bloc un peu plus haut
c'est pas simplement une volonté c'est
également le fait de la capacité on a
vraiment les joueurs adaptés pour avoir
cette cette philosophie de jeu de
stratégie ça a porté ses fruits en pré
saison on a gagné notre image
championnat on a gagné notre premier
match de coupe de france donc pour
l'heure on est quand même satisfait de
ce qui est proposé on a encore beaucoup
de travail certes mais mais voilà on
fonctionne tous ensemble que soit le
coach le staff les joueurs la présidence
pour voilà pour pour avoir à la fois une
cohérence en dehors du terrain et sur le
terrain pour lancer dans le même sens et
pour l'instant ça nous réussit plutôt
pas mal quel est l'objectif
justement cette saison l'année dernière
ou plus ethier a sauvé in extremis avec
le comité 19 qui avait arrêté le
championnat cette année
vous voulez pas vous faire peur alors
clairement on a eu on a eu les mots du
président donc me suivrait une mouche et
de décharges a redit notre coach on
on arrive en étant très ambitieux même
entre nous les joueurs on souhaite
vraiment jouer les premiers rôles cette
année dans la montée en l1 pourquoi pas
donc c'est clairement jouer les premiers
rôles dans les trois quatre équipes qui
vont pourquoi pas monter et accéder au
championnat supérieur et comme je le
répéte en début d'émission faire une
belle épopée en coupe de france c'est
vraiment là les deux points sur lequel
on souhaite donc soit axé notre notre
football cette année
prochain match contre champigny le 27
septembre prochain pour le compte de la
seconde journée une victoire forcément à
l'extérieur ça serait bien ce serait
bien d'enchaîner une seconde victoire en
championnat voilà je vous cache pas que
on prend les matches les uns après les
autres sans forcément commencé en
faisant des calculs ça va être un match
très difficile
une équipe de champigny très accrocheuse
mais mais aura clairement on se déplace
pas pour faire un match nul si on peut
aller attraper les trois points on va on
va pas se gêner en tout cas c'est l'état
d'esprit qu'on va essayer d'imposer dès
le début dernière question est-ce que
vous avez un message à faire passer aux
supporters de trappes pour cette
nouvelle saison
on espère qu'ils viennent nous sommes
finis supporter aussi nombreux qu ils
ont été depuis maintenant deux ans au
stade sans sac
non vraiment c'est un plus pour nous et
un moins que les adversaires donc s'ils
pouvaient garder leur fidélité
franchement ce serait super pour nous on
les remercie du fond du coeur et on va
essayer de se battre pour bien
représenter la ville le message est
passé en tout cas merci à vous d'être
venu sur ce plateau bon courage pour la
suite du championnat
la prochaine rencontre de championnat
pour trap est programmée le 27 septembre
prochain sur le terrain de champigny on
continue par de la nationale 2 de
football rien ne va plus pour les club
yvelinois poissy a concédé sa troisième
défaite de la saison contre granville ce
samedi le score 2 1
de son côté a versé et enregistre
également sa troisième défaite de la
saison contre saint apre yves et hilaire
le score est également de 2 1 aux
classements versailles 14e sur 16 fois
ci est bon dernier du championnat
on continue à parler de l'ess poids s'il
sera sans doute l'une des stars de cette
équipe cette saison et le club aura
besoin de lui pour remonter au
classement son nom clément chantôme
ancien joueur de l'équipe de france et
champion de france à deux reprises avec
le paris saint germain il joue dans les
yvelines depuis le mercato hivernal le
milieu de terrain répondu à notre
interview express regarder à la séquence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que mon père et arbitres donc ils
m'ont emmené tous les week-ends sont un
terrain de foot donc ça m'a donné envie
tout simplement quand j'ai été champion
de france avec le paris fondement
parce que c'était mon club formateur
donc d'être champion de france c'était
pour moi un aboutissement
moi pour l'instant c'est de faire une
belle année avec poissy après me lancer
dans une carrière d'entraîneur
si tout se passe bien en tout cas on va
essayer on va passer les diplômes et ça
me plaît pourquoi pas on verra
pour être tout à fait complet sur les
résultats de football on joue est
également ce week-end sur les terrains
de nationale 3 le fc mantois 78 remporté
son premier match de la saison contre le
paris fc lors de cette troisième journée
le score 1 0 classement le club du nord
du département est à la 9e place du
classement avec déjà deux défaites au
compteur on ouvre maintenant une page
rugby en fédérale 2 plaisir qui n'a pas
pu s'entraîner correctement suite à des
suspicions de kobe 19 dans l'effectif
s'est incliné 25 à 24 sur la pelouse du
stade poitevin rugby pour la reprise du
championnat après ce résultat plaisir et
6e du classement plaisir à qui
retrouvera son stade robert barran ce
dimanche à l'occasion de la 2e journée
du championnat de fédérale 2 les
plaisirs roi vont recevoir l'équipe de
chartres à 15h objectif une victoire
pour lancer la saison et surtout
grappiller des points en vue du maintien
si vous voulez assister à la rencontre
l'entrée est libre hommes ont joué est
également sur les terrains de fédérale 3
verset a parfaitement lancé sa saison en
s'imposant 18 à 14 sur le terrain de
vincennes
dans un match serré jusqu'au bout au
classement les versailles et son nom les
équipes de tête avant leur prochaine
rencontre du 19 septembre sur le terrain
de massif central on continue à parler
du rugby-club de versailles les
versailles en préparer a très tôt cette
nouvelle saison entre mercato et
renforcement de l'équipe seniors avec
des jeunes du club
objectif une montée en fédérale 2 un
reportage de bixente meriane santisteban
malgré l'excitation de pouvoir enfin
reprendre le championnat les entraîneurs
du rugby-club de versailles veille à ce
que les joueurs gardent leur sérieux le
club qui évolue actuellement en fêtard
halle 3 se veut ambitieux pour cette
saison on a tout préparé on a eu le
temps justement de préparer
cette ses équipes l'objectif de cette
saison c'est
faire partie des trois quatre premiers
de poule pour jouer la qualification
pour jouer les premiers rôles dans son
championnat
le rcv a procédé à un recrutement ciblé
objectif renforcer son effectif avec au
compteur deux nouvelles recrues le poste
de première ligne qui était un poste un
petit peu un petit peu compliqué donc on
absolument recruter sur sur les
premières lignes
et après à chaque à chaque poste on a
essayé de d'agrémenter un petit peu par
par un joueur en parallèle le club
prenne toujours la formation des jeunes
et le beau jeu comme élément clé de la
saison
comme tous les ans le but du rcv c'est
de grandir grandir comme j'ai déjà dit à
chaque année c'est grandir avec sa
formation grandir avec ces jeunes donc
on a intégré
déjà cette année encore cinq juniors de
l'année précédente
déjà 200 entraîne un petit peu te
démarquer du du groupe
le jeu à versailles et c'est un peu le
jeu rugby que souhaite avoir
nous on restera sur cette directrice
c'est à dire voilà avec beaucoup
d'envolées beaucoup de prises
d'intervalles des prises d'initiatives
de l'évitement et je pense que c'est
comme ça qu'on arrivera à atteindre nos
objectifs
cette identité de jeu s'est avérée
concluante le club versailles et a lancé
sa saison le dimanche 13 septembre par
une victoire 18 14 sur le terrain du rc
vincennes la promesse d'un début de
saison à la hauteur des attentes
en fédérale 3 mais cette fois ci dans la
poule une le derby vinoy entre houilles
carrières sur seine et le mlsgp a tourné
en faveur des joueurs locaux
le roc s'impose 36 à 18 face à son
voisin heavy noah et monte dans le top 5
du championnat
prochaine journée la semaine prochaine
le mlsgp recevra roubaix et où ira
défier lille métropole
on prend maintenant la direction de
montigny le bretonneux en plein tour de
france la fête du vélo était organisé ce
week end dans la commune au programme
quatre circuits sur trois jours et
notamment des parcours pour toute la
famille au départ du gymnase ladoumègue
les images de nicolas dandy jules grande
ville pour le montage
c'est une tradition à montigny le
bretonneux comme lors de chaque rentrée
le vélo club de la ville organise sa
fête du vélo du 11 au 13 septembre
quatre circuits vtt sont proposées au
public ce samedi des courses loisirs
dont 1 18 et 1 25 km étaient au
programme
le parcours donc le bois du manet
changarnier domaines port royal et ils
vont avoir un ravitaillement qui va se
situer à mi parcours à peu près une
quinzaine de kilomètres où ils vont
pouvoir se restaurer un petit bois sont
un petit sachet sucré et après ils
reviendront ici où ils recevront une de
nouveau une petite collation pour finir
la journée
cette année pour cette 28e édition 4 120
coureurs se sont inscrits pour
participer au rendez-vous loisirs du
samedi malgré les conditions sanitaires
du moment était hyper important de toute
façon je la fais pratiquement tous les
ans je suis un abonné à cette journée
sympathique et donc je viens tous les
ans il ya deux ou trois ans la dernière
fois qu'on a fait cette course on était
fini on avait terminé bon dernier parce
qu'on avait pris beaucoup de plaisir à
à regarder le paysage et à vivre
vraiment cette beauté dans le 78 donc
depuis je retourne avec mon ami qui me
traîne souvent j'aime bien rouler avec
le vélo c'est drôle quand on est de la
forêt à faire des bosses partout et
aller en forêt un vélo c'est forcément
écolo et ce à des randonnées encore plus
le dimanche le rendez-vous affiché
complet 500 sportifs se sont élancés sur
des raids compétition de 62 à 75 km
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition du golfe maintenant une
dose de bonne humeur c'est le cocktail
depuis 27 ans du trophée à sport passion
l'eau rendez vous décaler cette année du
mois de mai à ce jeudi 10 septembre à
cause du coc u19 a réuni des sportifs de
haut niveau sur le golf de feucherolles
ici a pas d'enjeu sportif mais des
parties amicales on écoute les réactions
micro de tv 78 ils ont tous répondu
présents ou presque puisque on est au
total on va être 186 personnes
aujourd'hui quand habituellement on et
210 220 personnes donc
donc pour moi c'est un vrai vrai succès
toujours heureux de répondre à
l'invitation de d'origine pour le 27ème
édition c'est un plaisir de partager
notamment nos sports respectifs
c'est uniquement rigoler c'est il ya
aucun aucun enjeu de performance la
compétition c'est très très loin d'ansé
juste juste faire plaisir une très très
bonne ambiance autour du sport que
j'aime le plus au monde un sport qui
m'accompagne depuis mon plus jeune âge
donc j'ai toutes les raisons d'être ici
il y aura bien sûr une nouvelle édition
du trophée sport passion en 2021
je vous propose maintenant de rencontrer
une personne hors du commun à seulement
21 ans thomas d'eric a déjà réalisé
plusieurs défis dont une marche de 140
km dans le désert bolivien
cet été il a réussi à traverser avec sa
copine justin andres la france du nord
au sud
nous l'avons rencontré pour débriefer
cette aventure
[Musique]
thomas d'eric vous avez 21 ans vous
habitez à monti le bretonneux et vous
avez réalisé une aventure cet été est ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter cette
aventure
oui tout à fait j'ai traversé la france
en rollers et à vélo avec ma petite amie
justine andres qui est originaire des
vosges est ensemble on est partis de
lille le 18 juin et on a traversé la
france jusqu'à la frontière espagnole
notre arrivée s'est faite le 25 août et
voilà après plus de deux mois d'aventuré
on était super content d'avoir traversé
la france pour moi en rollers pour elle
à vélo
suite à sa blessure elle a débuté en
rollers et elle a continué à vélo et
ensemble on est arrivé à la la ligne
d'arrivée c'était c'était vraiment un
moment chouette alors pourquoi avez vous
décidé de traverser la france en rollers
pourquoi les rollers parce que c'est un
moyen de déplacement assez originale
j'ai presque jamais vu d' aventure faite
en rollers donc je me suis dit pourquoi
pas essayer et je trouve qu'elle est
plus lentement au rythme des roulettes
c'est une manière de découvrir le c'est
une bonne alternative en fait entre le
vélo et la marche
on voit là c'est pour ces raisons là
est-ce que c'était dangereux sur le bord
des routes
c'est dangereux oui dans les descentes
en fait quand roller on prend plus de
place qu'en vélo sur une route parce
qu'on fait un balayage avec les pieds et
ça ça fait que les voitures vont plus
facilement nous frôler elles vont aussi
moins faire attention à nous parce
qu'elle ne considère pas comme un
véhicule
contrairement à vélo et du coup on n'est
plus en danger vis-à-vis des véhicules
aussi du dénivelé et c'est plus physique
donc on peut être plus facilement
fatigués faire et chuter alors je crois
savoir qu'il y ait eu quand même un
petit peu de casse pendant ce périple
oui justin à la commencer en rollers et
au bout de 200 km l arrivée à reims elle
s'est blessée elle et elle est tombée et
elle s'est fait une luxation de la
rotule du genou et ça a été un par
moments un peu difficiles parce qu'on ne
savait pas si elle allait pouvoir
reprendre l'aventuré heureusement elle a
pu continuer en vélo et elle a été très
résiliente et moi j'ai fait une chute
l'avant dernier jour mais ça va alors
c'était une aventure sportive à la base
mais c'est devenu une aventure humaine
c'est bien ça oui on est parti dans
l'objectif de
on est parti dans l'objectif de faire
une aventure sportive est en fait au fil
des rencontres on a tous les soirs
sonner chez des gens on a commencé à
aller tranquillement à prendre notre
temps le matin le soir à prendre l'apéro
et du coup on a été finalement notre
motivation c'est on voulait plus pour
avancer on voulait pour rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes
est ce que tous les soirs vous avez
trouvé un endroit où dormir
justement oui tous les soirs qu'on s'est
offert quelques nuits de 3 nuits en
camping dans certaines stations
balnéaires où c'était vraiment par
fatigue qu'on avait on n'avait pas envie
d'insister avait demandé à plein de gens
parce qu'on considère qu'on demande que
si on est en forme et qu'on va être en
capacité de partager avec les gens on va
pas chez les gens pour s'endormir au
bout de cinq minutes
mais sinon tous les autres soirs de l'
aventure on a trouvé des logements donc
souvent des jardins et quand les gens
sont enclins à nous accueillir à ouvrir
encore plus la relation il nous
accueille dans la maison directement
est ce que ça vous a surpris pensez
peut-être que ça va être plus difficile
honnêtement oui parce que je pense que
c'est le voyage le plus dépaysant que
j'ai fait en tout cas c'est celui qui a
le plus remis en question mes certitudes
je pensais que c'était possible je le
faisais à l'étranger parce que j'étais à
l'étranger et me rendre compte que c'est
possible aussi en france c'était
vraiment un bouleversement pour moi de
voir qu'en fait c'est possible partout
et surtout chez moi vous avez traversé
un désert de sel par exemple en bolivie
est-ce que c'était finalement plus dur
en roller c'est pas les mêmes
difficultés à traverser un désert de sel
à l'autre bout du monde
parce que c'est difficile ont éprouvé
par la solitude le poids du sac les
dangers mais on est seuls les risques
dépendent de nous et la réussite aussi
alors qu en rollers on est soumis au
flot de voitures qui passent à côté de
nous n'importe qui peut m'écraser à
n'importe quel moment
finalement j'ai beaucoup moins de
contrôles que dans un désert de sel est
ce qu'il ya eu des moments de doute
pendant cette aventure des moments
difficiles ouais la blessure de justin
c'est un moment difficile j'ai dû
repartir seul pendant une semaine
finalement ça s'est très bien passé
j'avais peur de ne pas être accueilli
je me disais peut-être que c'est parce
qu'on est en couple que ça fonctionne et
en fait sur cette nuit j'ai passé cinq
nuits dans des maisons pas dans le
jardin vraiment invitée chez les gens ça
c'est encore mieux passé et après ça on
quand elle a pu revenir on était plus
fort que jamais on était prêt à
affronter des blessures les difficultés
non ça s'est super bien passé par la
suite
quelle était la sensation à l'arrivée
c'était fou c'est incroyable d'arriver à
la frontière franco espagnole après plus
de 1300 km en roller le temps il est
tellement lent roller ça prend
énormément de temps de parcourir une
telle distance du coup on ne réalise pas
qu'on l'a fait la distance entre la
frontière franco-espagnole les points de
départ nous paraît presque surréaliste
mais c'était vraiment un moment faut
être con à partager l'ensemble c'est un
bon moment
c'était deux mois d'aventuré ce que vous
aviez tabler sur deux mois d'aventuré
peut-être un peu plus peut-être un peu
moins je m'étais laissé jusqu'à fin août
donc on a tenu on a finalement réussi
notre objectif on est arrivé le 25 août
mon but c'était presque d'aller le plus
lentement possible j'aurais voulu faire
durer l'aventuré le plus longtemps
possible je n'avais envie de faire plus
de rencontre encore des dormir encore
chez des gens de rouler à nouveau mais
dans l'ensemble c'était la durée qu'on
s'était fixés
thomas d'eric vous avez 21 ans je le
rappelle est ce que vous avez d'autres
aventures en tête tu penses à paris
dakar en auto stop potentiellement et
puis plein de choses encore
mais mon l'avenir l'avenir peut me
surprendre et me donnait envie de faire
d'autres projets que je ne connais pas
encore on verra bien est ce que vous
êtes toujours dans l'optique de vous
dépasser
oui je pense que c'est l'objectif mais
là où je suis parti dans les déserts de
ciel avec l'objectif de faire des défis
physiques et peut-être un record même qu
succès un record de jeunesse aussi
maintenance et je suis plus orienté sur
des rencontres humaines jeu peu importe
la difficulté de du voyage tant qu'il ya
beaucoup de rencontres ça me satisfait
même si je pense tout de même repartir
tout seul à l'assaut d'un autre désert
un jour où ils sont en tout cas merci
thomas d'eric une autre séquence se
découverte dans ce set 8 sport du 11 au
13 décembre le club des pyramides de
port marly accueilli l'un des tournois
les plus prestigieux du circuit français
de padel l'occasion pour nous de vous
faire découvrir un sport de plus en plus
en vogue en france et surtout dans les
yvelines un reportage de bixente mais
rien senti steban la discipline tire ses
origines d'une légende en 1969 un
mexicain fait construire un petit
terrain de tennis faute d'espacé sur sa
propriété
le paddle est ainsi née la pratique
réunit aujourd'hui 70 mille joueurs en
france
mélange de plusieurs sports de raquettes
sa spécificité et la présence de
paroisse autour du terrain on peut y
faire rebondir la balle pendant un
échange
la particularité du padel c'était un
sport ludique c'est addictif qui est
assez facile d'accès puisqu'en fait la
raquette est assise assez courte
on approche de la main et
très convivial parce que ça se joue sous
six mois à quatre la communication est
le socle de ce sport qui se pratique par
paire pour ces deux joueurs
professionnels de l'équipe de france
cela permet d'exploiter au mieux les
qualités de chacun jaunes viennent du
tennis et moi je suis un joueur perd
paddle donc je pense que ça se combinant
bien joey va vite vers l'avant joue très
fort mais moi je suis un peu plus avec
les vitres on veut plus avec les faits
le travail de celui qui ne joue pas ces
deux d'annoncé où sont les adversaires
sont partenaires de donner les
informations pour mettre un meilleur
boulot possible c'est un travail
invisible a été très important et sur un
match pour établir une stratégie de jeu
efficace il est essentiel de connaître
son partenaire on a une idée de départ à
savoir ce qu'on fait après on va essayer
surtout se concentrer sur nos points
forts à l'un à l'autre savoir ce qu'on
sait déjà bien faire dans un premier
temps pour essayer de se sentir à l'aise
individuellement à des particularités
après il faut que les particularités
s'emboîtent cette activité aussi intense
que ludique est de plus en plus présente
dans les yvelines
plusieurs clubs existent au port marly à
bois d'arcy opecst ou encore à bailly on
termine par du basket trappe débute son
championnat ce week-end contre eux à
bihorel dans son gymnase paul mallet et
genre trappistes auront à coeur de
remporter cette première victoire de la
saison eux qui vise une possible montée
en nationale 2 cette année
pour cela le recrutement était
conséquent si vous voulez voir cette
nouvelle équipe la rencontre débute à
20h c'est à la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]